Was there almost a plan for a new actor to
play T'Challa after Chadwick Boseman's tragic death?
2020 saw the tragic passing of Chadwick Boseman.
The T'Challa actor died from colon cancer
months before "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
was set to begin production.
In light of the tragedy, Marvel Studios postponed
the highly-anticipated sequel, giving the
cast and crew time to grieve over the late
actor and decide on next steps.
Director Ryan Coogler and Marvel Cinematic
Universe architect Kevin Feige ultimately
decided not to recast the role of T'Challa,
a decision that led to mixed reception from
some fans.
"He was king and Black Panther to everyone."
While some fans petitioned the studio to recast
the King of Wakanda, Marvel VP of Development
Nate Moore made it very clear: T'Challa will
not be seen on screen again out of respect
for Boseman.
He revealed on the Ringer-Verse podcast in
November 2021, months after "Wakanda Forever"
had started production,
"When Chad passed, it was a real conversation
we had with [director Ryan] Coogler about,
'What do we do?'
and it was a fast conversation.
It wasn't weeks, it was minutes of we had
to figure out how to move that franchise on
without that character.
Because I think we all feel so much of T'Challa
in the MCU on the screen ... is tied to Chadwick's performance."
The marketing for "Wakanda Forever" has directly
confirmed that T'Challa has passed in-universe,
though it remains to be seen how Coogler and
co-writer Joe Robert Cole tackle it.
Scrapping away the original idea for the "Black
Panther" sequel may have been difficult, but
from the rave social media reactions "Wakanda
Forever" has received, it seems that Coogler
has delivered another winner.
But while Moore emphasized how quickly the
decision had to be made, Ryan Coogler has
confirmed that he considered recasting T'Challa
at one point.
The director recently appeared on Marvel Studios'
"Wakanda Forever: The Official Black Panther"
podcast to discuss the sequel.
The nearly 40-minute long chat dived deep
into the world of Wakanda, how the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has evolved, and how Chadwick
Boseman's death influenced and changed the sequel.
The conversation eventually led to the director
being asked to discuss the significance and
responsibility of a new actor taking on the
role of Black Panther.
Coogler candidly replied,
"You consider everything, when something like
that happens, it's like 'I don't think I can
come back and make another one, I don't think
I can do this.
I don't think there should be another one.'
You go through all of the extremes."
Getting emotional, Coogler confirmed that
recasting was considered an option before
opening up about why the thought of recasting
dissipated, and it all boils to being honest
and seeking out the truth.
He continued by opening up about how his job
as a director is to spend hundreds of days
convincing his cast and crew to believe in
ideas that he finds truthful.
"I have to believe in something enough to
go convince other professionals to believe
in it as well for an extended period of time."
Expanding on that sentiment, Coogler explained
how his responsibility is to "weed out" anything
in the film or creative that screams, quote,
"nope" to him.
"I have [to have] a fighting chance of putting
something out in front of the audience, that
the audience can believe in and not be taken
out of for two hours ... they have to believe
in some kernel of truth that's happening on
the screen."
In the pursuit of his truth, which shaped
"Wakanda Forever," Coogler was clear about
one thing:
"Chadwick's gone from the physical sense,
he wasn't walking through that door ... he
was the guy."
Coogler recognized that if he himself didn't
believe in the idea of recasting T'Challa,
there was no truth in his vision.
"For somebody else to be him, for us in the
world that we created, we wouldn't have believed it.
No matter how good the actor was, it would've
been lacking the necessary truth for us to
do a good job."
It sounds like the idea of seriously recasting
Boseman's iconic role wasn't a path that Coogler
was interested in going down.
The writer-director had some more fond words
for the dearly departed actor, saying,
"Our truth was lost, which is a fact of life.
It's the gift and the curse of life.
Heroes, great men, die."